estas tres jóvenes están desempleadas
desde el principio de la pandemia
y organizó eventos estoy en arte desde
marzo
de personas latinoamericanas
entre abril y junio españa registró más
de 30.000 nuevos jóvenes desempleados
eso sin contar aquellos como inés que
trabajan a tiempo parcial yo creo que la
situación en españa es más grave que en
otros países de europa principalmente
porque españa es un país de servicios y
aquí casi todo el mundo se dedica al
turismo todos los castings de andrea
ruiz han sido cancelados de modo que
tuvo que pensar una estrategia para
seguir aplicando y poder enviar a
productoras casting y demás que esta
coreografía así que ya la monté yo y
bueno eso es un poco lo que intentamos
hacer ahora para que esta situación no
nos apalanque no nos deje sin hacer nada
en españa 43 9% de los menores de 25
años están sin empleo un récord en la
unión europea en este barrio popular de
madrid las cifras no sorprenden si no
molestan
una vergüenza porque además está súper
desmotivado y hay gente que estudia y
sabe que está la cosa mal
para mí ahora mismo no es que sea malo
pero tampoco es que digan puedo vivir
más o menos bien sabes y tenía que
volver claro un fenómeno social que
influye sobre el comportamiento familiar
según este psicólogo javier urra lo
llama adolescencia prolongada
hace que los chicos sean vuelvo a
repetir presentista viven el aquí y el
ahora porque el futuro es algo
imprevisible para ese psicólogo el
porvenir de estos jóvenes es un
verdadero interrogante el apoyo a una
revalorización de la formación
profesional porque en cambio los oficios
manuales si los siguen contratando